okay so I'm seeing a few people on the
right track just a quick note for
yourself we already know within this
topic that there's lots of derivatives
flying around okay
and even in related rates we were
looking at all kinds of different ones I
find it helpful to write for myself here
that velocity is DX on DT and then go
ahead and work out because as you'll see
later on it becomes crucially important
that we can differentiate with respect
to different variables just like we saw
in with related rates and balloons
there's radius as the area all those
different kinds of things so can someone
stick for me their derivative why don't
you begin with 10 PI 10 pi cos PI on 12
T fantastic so you've just use chain
rule once okay do remember sine goes to
cosine you're focusing on so many things
it's really easy to make a sign error
here sorry a plus/minus error here
because you forget am i differentiating
am i integrating which what am i doing
okay so this looks good
how can I read the maximum speed off
this yeah so the maximum speed comes
from the amplitude of the velocity
function right the further that the
velocity function is away from V equals
zero the faster that you are going in
either direction okay why can't you ask
about maximum velocity or why don't they
ask about max and velocity really do you
think matter what do you I can decalin
so since yeah velocity has direction in
mind right I suppose if someone asks for
maximum the positive one would be the
only one that makes sense but really
speed is the only one that's really
interesting and in either direction it
doesn't matter so I'm going to say 10 PI
I'm not quite done having done that
because the speed of course has to have
units attached to it what is this
kilometres per hour
no it's meters per second and where did
you get that from the question yeah came
from them give you the amplitude in
meters and the period in seconds so this
is meters per second right happy so now
in puppy they're going to ask us to use
these equations to solve for particular
parts of when those are equal to
particular values what is the first time
when it is 30
to the right of the origin and to the
left of the origin okay now before I I'm
on off to actually have a go at these
right let's interpret what equations
will I write down and then subsequently
solved with these two actually take all
those words and get something meaningful
either right displacement being 30
minutes 30 meters to the right of the
origin so if it's displacement which of
these two equations do I care about
displacement it's the top one right as I
sort of wrote down so I'm going to solve
for X being 30 meters to the I don't
like this because it says forwards and
backwards of ministers left and right
jerks anyway maybe they edited it they
say to the right first so do you think
that is the positive direction for X or
the negative direction most usually is
the positive direction to be honest you
can define it however you like but let's
define it as the positive one because
it's nice and easy to begin with so I'm
gonna be solving for positive 30 okay
and when you have a go up part two
what's the difference because that's
it's still 30 right but what will be the
different equation I write to get me a
different answer for time I'm still
going to be solving for x but it's x
equals negative 30 right so you've got
your equation up here solve it once for
x equals 30 you want the first time so
remember this is oscillating up and down
it's gonna be at that position and
infinite number times but you want the
first one okay so why don't you have a
crack at both see what you get out of
your equations if you have a value for
time core seven we'll have a look and
see if you're on the right track radio
so I want to sort of give you a bit of a
nudge in the right direction so let's
see if we can help each other out here
and what I've done here you can see in
my working all I've done is I have taken
what you told me to do I'm solving from
when x equals 34 when displacement is 30
here is my displacement equation from
Part A
okay that you help me work out and I've
gone ahead and I've let it equal 30 and
then seen what happened okay now I
didn't get to this point what are we
trying to find it's a time that we're
after right
what's the first time so this T is what
I'm really trying to dig into right so
at this point I have no choice I have to
do something violent to this equation to
get T out of those brackets what am I
going to have to do it's tucked inside a
sign at the moment right
so what way you're going to get rid of
that phone you're going to use the
inverse now it's tempting to write this
like so okay but you kind of have to be
careful here because this is why we
spent so long as a topic right inverse
functions are not just very simply the
opposite of their functions that they
came from right this guy over here this
line rather has an infinite number of
solutions yeah this one only has one
solution we restricted the domain for
that express purpose of making it a
function not a relation right so the the
line we've written here is ever so
slightly different to the one you have
here and you have to be careful with
them okay now how many of you wrote down
this line it's up yeah okay that must be
ready that's fine now when you do this
you get you know there's a number that's
going to come out from this and I could
say well I actually don't want pie on
12t I just want T so you could multiply
both sides by 12 on pi and that would
give you this like so okay now I saw
this on a lot of people's pages and I
said how confident are you that the
answer is what it is that that's the
answer and very few of you gave me
anything more than a maybe okay now
that's okay to have that and not be sure
it's the answer but I want to do better
than that I want actually know is this
reasonable or not okay so if you haven't
already reached for your calculator okay
the question did not ask you to do this
but I have no idea what this number is
I don't know my sine inverse is very
well off the top of my head especially
not for a number like that okay and when
you multiply by 12 on PI I'm completely
out to sea but to work out whether this
is a sensible answer I do need to work
out what this is okay so you have your
calculator there has someone got a
number on this 0.96
dot dot dot dot okay now does this make
sense as an answer hmm
still I'm still iffy about it right now
for starters what units is this in what
units do you think this is in this is a
time and earlier here I stated that I
was in seconds right so I'm guessing
this is in seconds
question mark okay now earlier on I drew
the graph over here is a very very rough
one okay I'm gonna encourage you if you
haven't already to do so now they don't
ask you to draw a graph but we know how
useful graphs are in sort of
interpreting what's happening now how do
I use this graph to sense whether this
is a reasonable answer or not okay
well this graph has this equation and I
wrote that equation on the basis of some
information they gave me right so the
period is 24 seconds where is 24 seconds
on this graph where is it if the period
is 24 seconds hmm
where should I write it where are you
pointing sinner at the end which end can
you be a little more specific at the end
of the sine curve I'm guessing this is
what you mean yeah good guess yes not
that was the correct answer okay great
so that is the right spot this is the
time axis after all I also have 120
where does that belong on this graph you
have to be a little more specific now
yeah thank you
oh hold on it's on the vertical axis
which we usually call Y right so I'll
pay that there we go but of course in
this instance it's actually not it's not
the y axis in this case is it's the x
axis very good so there's 120 but we're
trying to find when x equals 30 for the
first time where is that well this is
120 right then a 30 will be like 1/4 the
way up to that so if that's 60 then that
will be 30 right there okay now if
that's 24 seconds what's half time there
half of the period should be 12 seconds
right now you tell me I hand drew this
graph I didn't have any template nothing
I just saw we there we go does it look
like a reasonable
laughter you think so case not my best
work but it'll do you right now there's
30 do you think that looks anything like
0.965 I think it looks pretty alright to
be honest right keep you in mind that
that's 12 so like yeah 1 1/10 1/12 of
that I'm pretty happy with it okay now
it's really important that you go
through this process of thinking does
this answer make sense or not because it
doesn't necessarily look like it does
okay but I can use this to then answer
the next question if I understand it
correctly right